la interminable espera es ahora la vida
cotidiana de los habitantes de haza en
el sur de Turquía sin hogar desde el
terremoto esperan conseguir algo para
sobrevivir en esta escuela donde ahora
se distribuye ayuda humanitaria
Tengo ocho hijos vivimos en una tienda
de campaña Hay algo en la parte superior
de la tienda y el suelo está mojado
pedimos más tiendas pero no nos dan
ninguna Aquí no hay ayuda suficiente
como atestigua esta voluntaria nos
faltan tiendas como en todas partes es
el mayor problema que tenemos el día del
primer terremoto la gente se quedó bajo
la lluvia se afinó en coches donde
tuvieron que quedarse todos juntos con
los ancianos los enfermos el miedo a
otro terremoto está en la mente de todos
especialmente en Estambul la megalópolis
turca 16 millones de habitantes y
rascacielos que han aumentado en los
últimos años aquí todo el mundo recuerda
el terremoto de 1999 que mató a un
millar de estambulitas según este
reputado sismólogo la probabilidad de
que otro terremoto devastador sacuda a
Estambul antes de 2030 es muy alta
me gustaría poder decir que Estambul
está preparada Pero por desgracia una
ciudad muy grande con una población
enorme Y hay muchos edificios antiguos
construidos antes de 1999 el suelo Es
malo y hay muchos edificios mal hechos
que son estructuralmente peligrosos
cuando fue elegido Primer Ministro en
prometió endurecer las normas de
construcción y los edificios existentes
el último terremoto redujo a polvo casi
medio millón de viviendas en el sur del
país y ha hecho tambalear el gobierno de
duan